herbie joins us congratulations herbie
great night for you last night thanks
for joining us
hey dan thanks a lot man crazy day with
everything going on in the morning and
then uh
you know to have that go on last night
that was uh
quite a quite a different emotional
swing here is how it sounded when herbie
won and herbie is in
probably the toughest category we're in
the best daily sports show
we're in that category but uh you know
herbie's in there with the best analysts
so you got collinsworth who's always
winning
tony romo's the new flavor here i mean
troy aikman's in there and here's the
announcement last night
i've won a few of these i've never
really been there to
accept them
i'm like the guy that can't believe
he got invited to be here with you guys
i'm just very
very appreciative of
uh being able to do something i love
you caught me off guard there herbie and
i'm sure you were caught off guard as
well but i'm i'm watching i'm going good
for herbie
and then all of a sudden i walked away i
came back i go
what's going on paul goes no herbie's
really emotional here and i go
oh well if if i win i have to
i have to have more tears than herbie
does and of course i didn't win but uh
why did it hit you
so strong there well you know i
i i just i don't you're staring at a
computer you're not you know you're not
at the ceremony you're
i don't know i could very easily just
kind of tip my cap and said hey thanks a
lot you know
i've been really really fortunate you
know between game day and
and the ones i've won individually i you
know i think i've won 14
now and five uh individuals so i it's
not like
oh my god i want it in me i think it was
just
i don't know just just um you just
mentioned the names that were in that
category and they
every time i'm in it they're they're
typically the same names
and it's just a kind of a pinch me
moment like
how the hell is it how how am i even
in this circle and um it's just
gratitude and i i just i
you know like you i love what i do and i
just
you know and i think it's maybe the
emotion comes from the kind of the world
we're in right now
and and just seeing the world that we
know
um be challenged you know just it just
makes me
kind of take a step back and just be
grateful
for what i have well it's a great moment
and
look i get emotional if somebody opens
an envelope
uh even if my name is is not mentioned
but uh you know we
we uh are approaching the buffalo bills
we've gone over three here
um so i don't know if you have any
advice on us herbie
[Laughter]
well you guys i remember i remember one
year i went
and you were up against bob costas for
like top
uh oh yeah studio host yeah
yeah i think costas won or something
like that and you
you went up yeah and uh well i had
written a speech
i had written a speech and the thing was
is costas was actually there
but i said i look i wrote this speech
like 10 years ago and i got to deliver
it and some of the people were dead
on the uh on my list there so i just
thought you know what let me go up there
and bob was fine with it because he
you know yeah bob bob loses him he
he used some door stops or whatever he
hands them out at halloween i think
[Laughter]
with with what happened yesterday and
i'm trying to figure this out
i just don't know if the big 10 and
pac-12 have different information
than the acc sec and the big 12 have
when it comes to this pandemic yeah
yeah they they must i mean and and you
know there are hot spots all over the
country
you know i know los angeles and
california through a lot of this
it has been considered a hot spot um
but i think the confusion that is out
there for a lot of people
is is that where is the leadership in
college football
right i hear that a lot where is the
leadership what's going on with the ncaa
as you know dan with with with college
football going to this power
five when there was all that realignment
they created the playoff when they
created the playoffs they got away from
the ncaa
because they became the power five
conferences and those
those power five conference
commissioners
became the leaders for college football
and i think what what is very apparent
to everybody
is instead of having one voice your hat
you have five silos
and those five silos are worried about
just their
presidents their their players their ads
their coaches basically their fans their
constituents
in that region and that's all they're
they're concerned about so
what's happening with the pac-12 what's
happening to the big ten
has nothing to do with with the acc the
and the big 12 the sec but i'm with you
you know we're relying on doctors we're
relying on data
relying on advice we have no idea about
infectious disease right guys like you
and i we
we just we listen to guys like dr fauci
tell us what we need to know
what i found interesting yesterday is
the big 10 is
is doing that and the pac-12 is doing
that canceling
and the same day the sec and the acc
doctors that that provide leadership for
them are saying oh no no
yeah we've got a clear we've got a clear
path to play and it's
it makes you just go wait wait wait how
did you have a clear path and again i
understand and respect the hot spots but
why can't all the doctors get on the
same page it's
frustrating i i just want these doctors
to release the information
and i would love to have all of these
doctors in the power five
conferences just so we know apples to
apples
what everybody's dealing with and can it
help us as
everyday citizens here like what what is
what
testing procedures are put in place
safeguards are are put in place
yeah i'm sorry to interrupt you but i
would just say that i think
if we step back up from the emotion of
we want football you know and just
look at what is hanging over the head
of these conferences because you if you
look at the data of 18 to 24 year olds
you could very easily say look at the
data i mean most of these cases are
asymptomatic
my kids are at clemson they play at
clemson they had 40 players at one point
a few weeks ago that were positive
my kids got a couple of their roommates
were both positive
they got dinged to be quarantined for
contact tracing
so they couldn't go over the facility
for two weeks it just gives you an
example of how
easily you could lose an entire roster
because not so much the positive cases
but the direct
uh direct contact and and to me
while we all want to say they're all
asymptomatic it's not that big a deal
you know as well as i do
all it takes is two or three or four or
five outliers in all of college football
kids that that all of a sudden you know
they're in the hospital they're in
intensive care
and all of a sudden that's a liability
for that conference commissioner for
that
athletic director for that coach and so
that's to me at the end of the day while
the pac-12
and the big ten pulled the plug i think
it's the risk it's the potential risk of
yeah maybe
90 of them are okay but what if
and now i got to look at those parents
in the eye and they're going to say
why did you green light us why did you
play football knowing the risk
so i think that just the potential of
that is why they decided to
to make that move he's kirk kerb street
espn college football
analyst and he won his fifth sports emmy
last night most of any
commentator in espn history if you're
justin fields
and you had the opportunity to transfer
first of all
should he get the opportunity to
transfer in your opinion and if so
would you do it well i
i think all the the big ten of the
pac-12 players
should have the right to look to be able
to go elsewhere
um just because of these extreme
circumstances
you know we're in a different era when
it comes to players having freedom to be
able to go
to another school and not have to sit
out and
these these would be to me is extreme
um this would be as extreme of a case
that you can imagine
i would say this as far as justin
specifically
he has an incredibly close relationship
with ryan day
not just man to man but ryan day is
looked at
as the cutting edge in all of football
when it comes to
breaking down defenses and knowing how
to attack them
the nfl people look at he and lincoln
riley like man these guys are
masterminds
and so i really think if you look at
him specifically that justin fields that
left georgia as a five star
didn't beat out jake fromm goes to ohio
state
and becomes a heisman candidate comes
back for this year
heisman candidate considered a first or
second pick
he's really grown underneath ryan day so
i would be shocked in that case that if
he would ever le he'd rather sit in a
film room and work out with ryan day
and continue to improve with ryan day
than i think he would want to do
elsewhere i would do that too i i would
stay
i'd just work out would you take justin
fields over
trevor lawrence man that's that's going
to be the big thing that
i think it would depend on the system
you know in the nfl let's jump in early
on this herby this could win you an emmy
next year
yeah yeah exactly uh the nfl man
oh it's crazy you know you go back to
ten really five years ago ten years ago
the quarterback in the nfl was
was peyton manning it was tom brady
right i mean these college quarterbacks
coming out of the big 12. it was like
wow he's too small
we don't you know in the college in the
pro game you got to fit in the pocket
and make the throws and you've got to be
6'4
and now kyla murray's out there right i
mean russell wilson's out there
lamar jackson's out there it's a
different game
for a lot of these offenses not all of
them but a lot of them and a lot of
these
these older coaches like andy reid who
have been west coast guys their entire
lives
got to make plays from the pocket
they're saying well look what the
college game is giving us
i've got to alter my scheme to patrick
mahomes coming out of texas tech
instead of making him alter his game
to my system like we've been doing for
15 years
i'm going to try to learn this this
offense and we're going to try to run it
and it obviously
worked out really well so i think that
trend is going to continue to grow so
with that in mind
i think justin fields is going to be a
guy that's going to be
dynamic at the next level i think his
skill set
the ability to throw the ability to run
the ability to create
is uh you know very very rare so
it'll be fun to see he and trevor work
out and and both
i think are going to be superstars but i
think justin may have an upper a little
bit of an upper hand just because of the
way
the nfl game is is uh kind of trending
the direction it's going
all right so long-winded waves saying
you might give the edge to justin fields
over trevor lawrence
yes sir okay that's what i want by the
way i just got to
i just got this in big 12 teams uh
their schedule they're going to open up
with a non-conference opponent
that would either be september 12th or
the 19th
the conference schedule would begin
september 26th
which i guess would coincide also with
the sec
starting as well but um non-conference
opponent
that might be they they could be playing
somebody in the sec as an unconference
opponent i guess
real quick thing about people being
bringing this up and it's good for your
listeners to think about two of the
power five are out
three are still standing would bill
hancock
in the playoff committee still have
a college football playoff with three
power five teams left
yes now that that i i think it's yes you
know i i don't know if they publicly
said that but
i i think they do that and i think uh if
it's you know if you lose another one
maybe you don't you know if there's only
two remaining but if there's three i
still think you would see them move
forward
with with the playoffs uh great to talk
to you herbie as always and once again
congratulations and uh hope the boys are
safe there clemson
thanks man great talking to you
appreciate it kirk kerbstreet joining us
on the program